now there's some fascinating benefits
with raw milk and raw milk products that
i'm going to talk about today
but if you
ask someone what is the most perfect
food for an infant um
i would imagine they would say breast
milk right because breast milk is
something that's been created over a
very long period of time as a survival
thing you can build a very healthy baby
on breast milk and if an infant is not
fed breast milk oh my gosh their risk
for all sorts of problems go way up
sudden into death syndrome obesity
diabetes allergies and the list goes on
and on and on our bodies were designed
to start out on breast milk so if breast
milk is so good why is cow's milk or
goat's milk so
bad
that's what i want to discuss well i
think it really has to do with the
quality of milk okay
pasteurization now i'm not saying that
there wasn't outbreaks of certain
diseases like tb and things long ago due
to sanitation
but if you have a healthy environment
for that cow and that cow is healthy
then what's really bad with milk first
thing is pasteurization well you might
want to say
we want to sterilize the milk to make it
really healthy to get rid of all the
bacteria in this milk this very
unhealthy pathogenic
substance
well
yes heat kills bacteria but it doesn't
get rid of bacteria when you're drinking
pasteurized milk you're drinking all the
dead bacteria that's in it but another
thing that happens when they pasteurize
the milk is they're killing all the
enzymes okay
enzymes are proteins there's over 2500
different proteins in milk okay and
they're
altering and damaging those proteins
they're denaturing those proteins and
i'm talking about
proteins that can help someone's immune
system like for example
lacto-peroxidase which is an
anti-bacterial
enzyme
that's destroyed when you pasteurize it
lactoferrin which is a protein
that starves off pathogens from iron
okay so
when you have pasteurized milk
that's destroyed the antibodies in milk
are also destroyed that is an immune
benefit that you won't have also lactase
bacteria are destroyed there are certain
bacteria that make the enzyme to get rid
of lactose okay and so those of us that
have lactose intolerance like myself
need lactase which is the enzyme that
breaks down lactose and in raw milk
there's that enzyme okay from that
bacteria so raw milk has a lot of
good bacteria that can help us now
there's also like 400 different types of
fatty acids
in raw milk that are destroyed when you
homogenize the milk okay homogenation is
about breaking up the fat into small
little particles that now you lose the
function of that fatty acid because
you're now mixing the cream with the
other part and it won't separate and i
don't know about you but my body
craves the cream on raw milk in fact i
could probably live on that cream it's
so delicious and it's so good for you it
has something called the waltzin factor
what is the waltzer factor that's an
anti-stiffness factor and i'm not going
to give you the long chemical name but
it's good for rheumatoid arthritis and
stiffness because it's anti-inflammatory
especially stiffness in your wrists now
i do want to say that i don't drink raw
milk i actually consume raw milk
products that are fermented okay
like raw milk cheese which i love by the
way
kefir and sometimes yogurt but mainly
kefir because it has a lot more friendly
bacteria and friendly yeast and raw milk
products there's a lot more bioavailable
calcium and fat soluble vitamins all
right you also have this enzyme right
here alkaline phosphatase which is
anti-inflammatory
so way back early in the 1900s there
were all sorts of people using raw milk
for
cures for all sorts of things to help
their ulcers their gi problems
inflammation in the gut to help with
allergies
gout
gum disease and even asthma now you
might say that raw milk is illegal in
your state
but if you go to real milk.com
there's actually if i'm not mistaken at
least 43 states that you can get access
to raw milk and sometimes you have to do
and i'm not even sure what this is
called but i think it's some type of
program where you're sharing that the
cow and you're getting a portion of that
cow which is milk but anyway you should
check this out realmilk.com there's a
lot of additional great data and lastly
i want to just mention the difference
between a1 and a2 milk okay this has to
do with the protein casein and milk
if given the chance get your milk from
a2
cows because
a2 is a type of protein
that has a lot less bloating a lot less
digestive inflammation
unfortunately the a1 protein type milk
is more inflammatory and you may find
more gi problems now if you have not
seen my video on consuming kefir to help
yourself sleep i put that video up right
here check it out
you